ah debt debt really stresses me out
thankfully I haven't had debt in a long
time that is God that's probably when I
think about all the stresses in my life
I think debt is by far the biggest
stress I've ever put on myself I can't
think of anything on such like that's a
good one ma'am
yeah and it's the thing about dead is
you you just said it perfectly it's the
thing that we put on ourselves oh yeah
yes someone else generally doesn't pour
debt on you there can be sort of medical
it's legal for here Josh I just bought
you a house four hundred thousand
dollars grab your hair babies make you
cider
yeah and so so that is really stressful
and and it was a stressor it was a
low-level stressor because I just sort
of ignored that that warning light was
on my entire 20s and then obviously in
my early 30s until I got out of debt
thirty-one thirty-two and and that light
was just there and you can't ignore it
because it's flashing all the time yeah
and so you just sort of pretend it's not
there it becomes part of your everyday
existence flash flash flash flash I used
to tell myself cuz someone had told
someone had told me you know it's good
to have a little bit of stress and
that's what I would tell myself when I
felt that indicator with the debt yeah
it's like oh I'm supposed to have a
little bit of stress in my life yeah but
in an you know there are the majority of
the people living in the United States
are in debt so you know I'm not saying
that uh if you have that like you know
it's this is such a touchy subject for
me man because what I want to say is is
yes we put it on ourselves yes and the
amount of debt that I had that was
giving me anxiety it was too much debt
and yes I should have been an indicator
for me to like to change it yeah I think
most people United States either have
that or have had that at some point in
time yeah and if you have that you're
broke I mean there's no other way to
really say it if there's means you can't
afford the thing they see you're much
more direct when it comes to the debt
than I but here's but here I'm saying
this in loving way like the way the way
I would say it's Ella when she's 15 or
16 and I would say hey if you have a
debt you're broke but here's here's the
good news
we've all been broke or broke in at some
period in time
that's okay what's not okay is to
continue to be broke or broken without a
plan to get out of that brokenness that
that we are experiencing
you